[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
audience here thank you all for coming
we're so glad you're here grab a seat
get comfortable
I feel like Arsenio Hall
thank you for being here
all right I gotta get the show started
uh thank you all for coming uh we do
have a great show tonight great lineup
the vague ramaswami on set with us right
here in studio
Senator Tim Scott right here in studio
and in just moments we're going to hear
from house Judiciary Committee chairman
Jim Jordan yeah now
today Jordan and other Republicans
confronted big time the Attorney General
Merrick Garland who frankly needs to be
impeached during what was an explosive
explosive hearing on Capitol Hill more
than half of the country no longer trust
Garland and for good reason Biden's
so-called justice system has become
weaponized and politicized like the FBI
beyond belief unequal prosecution
unequal sentencing unequal application
of our laws we don't have equal justice
under the law and a sitting president
who of course has been shielded
protected from any and all legal
scrutiny while his chief political rival
Donald J Trump has been targeted with
dozens of stacked charges in one of the
most aggressive prosecutions in American
history this has never happened to a
former president one time it's happened
four times perfectly timed interestingly
enough even though these issues go back
years for the 2020 for election season
but this is all news to Merit Garland
attorney general believes he's done a
heroic job he thinks he's great leading
a fair righteous department of justice
but for some reason well Garland just
wasn't willing to Able or able to answer
questions in any direct or forthcoming
manner as I kind of predict it take a
look
have you had personal contact with
anyone at FBI headquarters about the
hunter Biden investigation
ah
don't real I don't I don't recollect the
answer to that question but the FBI
works for the justice department it's uh
I'm sorry I'm sorry you don't recollect
you don't recollect whether you've
talked with anybody at FBI headquarters
about an investigation of the
president's son I I don't believe that I
did
I don't believe I don't remember I don't
recall willful ignorance was the theme
of the day for mayor Garland question
after question after question no Clarity
whatsoever Garland didn't seem to know
much about anything to be honest like
likely by Design I would think Garland
he's not a fool on day one he knew that
the old Biden family business was a huge
problem but luckily for Garland and of
course Joe Biden the solution was
already in progress thanks to Federal
prosecutor David Weiss Weiss has
seemingly never-ending investigation now
over five years long into Hunter Biden
allowed Garland to distance himself and
ignore all the questions about the
allegations against Joe and Hunter when
he became special counsel I told you
this would happen at the same time
Garland put a big show about his
Integrity his independence bragging that
he and Weiss had the Undisputed power to
bring charges anywhere any jurisdiction
knowing full well that Weiss was not
using that Authority at all and told the
IRS whistleblowers they didn't have the
authority and contradicted himself to
both Jim Jordan and Lindsey Graham after
getting turned away by Biden appointed
prosecutors another District well Weiss
was reportedly just simply content plan
a was to charge Hunter with nothing and
you know close the investigation it was
over now all of a sudden we had those
IRS whistleblowers show up and sound the
alarm take a look
you said he had complete Authority but
he'd already been turned down he wanted
to bring an action in the District of
Columbia and the U.S attorney there said
no you can't and then you go tell the
United States Senate under oath that he
has complete Authority I'm going to say
again that no one had the authority to
turn him down they could refuse to
partner with him they could not use
whatever you language refused to partner
is turning down
all right from the looks of all this
either Garland was lying under oath or
wife's did all the dirty work while the
Attorney General was pretending to bury
his head in the sand now of course the
Weiss case is now a disaster in every
single way multiple serious allegations
of misconduct from government
whistleblowers and an FBI whistleblower
followed by a highly unusual sweetheart
deal that was rejected by the judge
remember that was Plan B because they
didn't plan on originally charging
Hunter Biden okay whistleblowers show up
let's act like we'll give him a slap on
the wrist we'll insert in the plea
agreement in the gun charge provision
the diversion program oh full immunity
for Hunter no jail time uh and after
five years of investigating Weiss he
allowed the statute of limitations to
run out of some of the most serious tax
charges that during the Barista years
what a coincidence but despite all all
of this you know who Garland appointed a
special counsel to clean up David
Weiss's mask he appointed David Weiss of
course it's almost as if the goal is to
protect the big guy Joe Biden instead of
actually Prosecuting serious crimes look
at this
Mr uh Garland did you consider I just
want to go back to this question did you
consider anyone else
when David Weiss requested special
counsel designation on August 8th
oh Mr Weiss asked to be made special
counsel and I made I did not consider an
alternative I'm going to be clear he was
the only one under consideration it was
either no special counsel or if there
was a special counsel it was going to be
the guy who presided over the
investigation for the previous five
years they made an intentional decision
to say we're going to let the statute of
limitations lapse and I want to know who
decided that and why they did it
Mr Weiss was a supervisor of the
investigation at that time and at all
times he made the appropriate decisions
and you'll be able to ask him that
question and he will you know why they
did it everyone knows why they did it
may not say it but everyone knows why
they did it they didn't Baris those tax
years that's that that dealt with the
pre that involved the president it's one
thing to have a gun charge in Delaware
that doesn't involve the president
United States but barisma oh my that
goes right to the White House we can't
have that
why would Garland ever consider anyone
else why so ready to baste himself in
court sacrificed you're right sacrifice
his reputation to protect Joe Biden
right on cue though a couple of gun
charges plan C now against Hunter showed
up not against Joe the low-hanging fruit
now that the plea deal of course
imploded thanks to that Delaware judge
that actually read the plea agreement
asked the prosecution have you ever seen
a deal like this before and they gave
the answer no they never saw one then
why are you offering it to them and a
federal judge demanded action by the way
no fire violations the tax charges
statute of limitations go away nothing
that would implicate uh Hunter's father
the big guy Joe who Hunter gave half his
income to Pops and paid all of pops's
home repairs and we have the emails
proving that and by the way who has lied
Joe Biden has lied and changed his story
repeatedly and was up to his eyeballs
engaging with Hunter's business partner
years both here at home and abroad the
doj they'll go to Great Lengths to serve
Joe Biden and other democrats for that
matter if you are part of the BLM riots
tried to burn down a federal courthouse
in 2020 uh 574 rights if you doxed a
conservative Supreme Court Justices home
you surrounded them with angry mobs
Biden's doj was more than happy to let
you off the hook but if you were accused
of obstructing a sidewalk outside of an
abortion clinic legally get ready for a
SWAT team to come knock on your door
guns drawn full tactical gear followed
by several serious felonies
[Music]
prison sentence you all know it's true
we don't have equal justice Biden's
weaponized doj has no so much contempt
for you know what half the country that
they're criminalizing conservatives
while protection protecting the likes of
the clintons the bidens and anyone
that's a Democrat today Garland couldn't
even give a direct answer to this simple
question about traditional Catholics who
are allegedly targeted spied on by the
FBI and the doj because of their deep
Abiding Faith religious views look
Attorney General
through the chair I ask you do you agree
that traditional Catholics are violent
extremists
I have no idea what your what the
traditional means here let me just go to
church may I answer your question yes
idea that someone with my family
background
would discriminate against any religion
is so outrageous it's so absurds to
attorney general it was your FBI that
did this it was your FBI that was
sending and we have the memos we have
the emails we're sending undercover
agents into Catholic churches now our
justice system is broken our attorney
general is an arrogant deceptive
political hack and the vast majority of
employees at the doj are far left
Democrats with Trump derangement
syndrome it is a dark day for American
justice but we are still just one
election away from turning all of this
around hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else